Hey friends, I got a hot tip for you.
What would you say if I told you that I
can teach you how to get down any PO
trick in five simple steps?
[music]
Drex here from Drexfactor PO, sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video, I'm going to
guide you through my process for how I
learn new PO tricks in the hopes that it
helps you as well. But before we dive
in, I just want to give a quick shout
out to the friends of the channel. Big
thanks to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca,
Flowfests, Flow Toys, Pyroer Light Toys,
and Ultraoy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible. You can
learn more about all of these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video. So, this is a
skill that basically any PO spinner is
going to need to pick up at some point.
You see a video of somebody online doing
something that you think is really
amazing, and you want to figure out how
to get it down yourself. But how to do
it? The real answer, of course, is hard
work and practice. But there are some
tricks that'll help you get there just a
little bit faster. And I'm here to share
them with you. And to give you an
example of this in action, I'm going to
take you through the steps that I went
through to learn how to do gunslinger
anti-pin flowers several years ago, so
you can see these steps in action. So,
let's go ahead and start off with the
very first step.
Step one, study the game tape.
So, I think the first and probably one
of the most important steps for getting
down any move is to be able to really
understand everything that's going on
inside of it. And to do that, it's
helpful to be able to take the video of
that move and break it down as slowly as
you possibly can. Here's how. I use an
app called Repost. Basically, I can copy
a URL from Instagram and use it to
download a copy of another person's
video directly onto my phone. From
there, I can move through it frame by
frame if need be and watch it in as slow
motion as I could possibly want. The
benefits of this, of course, are that I
can go through and I can watch at my own
speed and I can make sure I'm just
watching the section that is either
giving me trouble or that I find most
interesting. It's really, really, really
helpful for being able to just zoom in
on a specific thing at a given time. In
the case of the gunslinger anti-pens,
there was actually a video by AOE Condo
that I first saw the move in and that I
wanted to learn it from. This involved
downloading the video from his channel
and being able to go through it step by
step, which was hugely helpful in
helping me understand what the move was
and what I needed to learn in order to
get it down. And in terms of actually
getting that trick down, the next step
may not be what you think. Step two,
practice what you already know. So, this
may seem counterintuitive, but stick
with me here. I really think the best
first step in learning any new trick is
to figure out what parts of the trick
you already know. The benefits of this
are really twofold. Rather than giving
yourself a crazy challenge right off the
bat, it instead makes parts of it feel
more accessible and it gives you a good
foundation for getting into the move.
Plus, which as you build more pieces
upon this, this becomes your foundation
for moving from point A to point B. Part
of the point of this exercise is to
break down the trick to its most basic
pieces. When you can see how those
pieces fit together, it becomes a lot
easier to build them back up into the
full thing. If you try to do the entire
trick all at once, it's like trying to
eat an elephant in a single bite. It's
pretty difficult and you're probably not
going to pull it off, at least not
easily. In the case of that gunslinger
flower, one of the initial things that I
discovered was that it was built out of
two meteor weaves that I already knew
how to do. One was a thumbled forwards
weave and the other was a pinkyled
reverse weave. Both two beats. And these
were the first things that I practiced
in getting down that gunslinger flower.
And then of course there was trying to
figure out how to put them together. But
we'll cover that in the next step. Okay.
So clearly this is where the process
begins and not where it ends. So what is
the next thing we need to tackle?
[music] Step three, the known unknowns.
Okay. So, it's good to know what the
basics are that are within your reach,
but it is also good to know what are the
things that you can recognize in the
trick that you don't currently have
access to and how to practice them. So,
whatever basics you started with,
inevitably, there's going to be another
step beyond them that's going to get you
closer to this trick. Something that you
can see that you need, even if you don't
quite know how to do it just yet. And
the next step of this process is to
begin to practice that. This is where
you take your linear extensions and
combine them together into full
patterns. This is where you take your
fountains and learn them both going in
spin as well as anti- spin. There's a
lot of different examples of this in
action, but suffice it to say, this is
when you start pouring on the challenges
for yourself and seeing if you can get
to point B from your point A. And once
again, in the example of these
gunslinger anti-pin flowers, what I
realized was in order to get back and
forth between the forwards and reverse
weaves, there was a little move that
I've come to realize is a linear
isolation that allowed me to shift
between thumb leading and pinky leading.
And coincidentally enough, it also
created that top pedal when I started
moving my hand up and down to turn this
waist wrap into a full flower. Cool. So,
you're trucking along and you're making
progress and then somebody throws you a
curveball. Step four, the unknown
unknowns.
It's inevitable as you're getting down
something new that you're going to
discover that there's some part of it
that is not currently in your wheelhouse
and that you need to put a bunch of work
into. Sometimes you can find other
people that have worked through the same
things that you have. And sometimes
you're working in a place where you kind
of have a unique challenge that you
yourself have to figure out a way
around. Either way, you want to identify
what that challenge is and come up with
something that you can practice
regularly to close the gaps for
yourself. One of the weirdest curve
balls that I encountered while learning
those gunslinger anti-pin flowers was
simply that there are phasings between
the hands in terms of how they handle
different meteor weaves. That is, they
can always be on the same side of my
body or they can be going in and out in
opposing phasings. And to perform the
flowers that I wanted to, I needed to
get down the ability to have both of my
hands performing those flowers parallel
on each side of my body at the same
time. This was a really specific and
unique exercise that I did not
anticipate coming, but I was able to
figure out a way to drill. Okay, so now
we have explored the things that we
know, explored the things that we knew
we didn't know, and we have explored the
things that we didn't know that we
didn't know. So, what could be left?
Step five, [music]
practice, practice, practice. So, it's
inevitable that when picking up
something new, it's going to take you a
lot of practice. And you can't sherk
that. It's really tempting when you
start encountering those unknown
unknowns to basically say that this
trick may be beyond your capabilities or
put down your po and just forget about
it for a while. But the thing is is that
there's an opportunity here to expand
your knowledge and expand your reach.
And you really have to be diligent about
doing that on a regular basis. Practice
every day if you can. Not just your
drills, but the basics of the trick as
well as the known unknowns. In the
process, not only will you make your
foundations more solid, but also too,
it'll put them in the realm where they
become unconscious to perform, and that
is what's going to allow you to connect
the dots into the unknown unknowns, too.
And I practiced a lot to get down that
gunslinger anti-pin flower. In fact, I
practiced daily for three solid months
before I finally made the dots connect
on Christmas Eve. And goodness, was it
ever satisfying. So, go forth, break the
thing down, build upon it, discover what
you don't know, and above all, practice,
practice, practice, and I guarantee you
any trick that you want will be
attainable. Did you get anything out of
this video? Please make sure to like,
share, comment, and subscribe to help
other people find it and to help my
channel grow.
[music]
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right [music] now. Thank you all
so much for supporting my channel, my
work, and my mission. And if you would
like to get your name in the credits or
access to a whole host of other rewards,
you can do that by checking out my
Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo.
I will include a link to that down in
the description as well as up in the
cards. This video was actually a request
from one of my Patreon supporters. So,
if you get on there, you can make your
voice heard and let me know what videos
you'd like to see as well. And of
course, more importantly, you'll be
helping me out in my mission to bring PO
spinning and flow arts to the whole wide
world. So, go check that out, please.
And thank you. And of course, learning a
trick is only part of the equation.
There's also teaching the trick. If
you'd like to learn some of my best tips
for how to become a better teacher, I
will go ahead and include a link to a
video on that topic up here on screen as
well as down in the description. Thank
you so much for watching. Make sure to
get out and flow today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon. Take care
now. Peace.